after some uncertainty the Obamacare
repeal in the US Senate is dead again
Republicans totally unable to unite
behind a plan to get rid of the
Affordable Care Act after threatening to
do it promising to do it for most of
Barack Obama's presidency we saw
Republican susan collins republican
republican lisa murkowski and of course
republican senator john mccain vote
against the repeal Trump saying that the
three had let the American people down
the last iteration that they tried was
what's being called a skinny repeal the
skinny repeal would have led not to the
reduction in obesity rates as the word
skinny might suggest but rather it would
have led to 16 million people losing
health insurance by 2026 as well as an
increase in premiums of 20% above and
beyond the current projections Senator
John McCain recently diagnosed with
brain cancer has been getting a ton of
attention around his vote against this
and Mike Pence was seen talking to
McCain for about 20 minutes right before
the vote but then McCain went over to a
group of Democrats who all seemed
thrilled to see him walk over and
ultimately McCain voting against this
repeal now I get that McCain's vote was
somewhat of a surprise but I think
people are going a little overboard Pat
and calling McCain the hero here I mean
Collins and Murkowski are just as
responsible for this as McCain all of
the other Democrats on to which these
three Republican votes were added to are
just as responsible for this as is John
McCain and by the way what about the
people that created Obamacare including
the former President Barack Obama yeah
John McCain has somewhat of a conscience
and that does distinguish him from a lot
of the Republican Party right now but it
doesn't making the savior here well sure
but I think we knew that all 48
Democrats would vote against any
Obamacare repeal efforts and as far as
Republicans are concerned I mean Susan
Collins and Lisa Murkowski were pretty
certain knows as well we just didn't
know which moderate was going to join
them if any if it was going to be McCain
or taffeta or Heller but that might have
someone that's my point which is while
it was surprising and sort of unknown
until the last moment
it's not anymore heroic and what I'm
thinking about more and more is Joe
Biden reportedly lobbied John McCain
before this vote which is interesting
and I believe it's time for John McCain
to leave the Republican Party not
because he's some progressive panacea
but because he's just not radical enough
to be in the Republican Party there's
lots of center-right in the Democratic
Party right now and John McCain once
considered leaving the Republican Party
I don't think there's really much of a
place for McCain in the Republican Party
right now well it seems like a lot of
Republicans voted for this knowing that
it would never actually be signed into
law because the next step would be to
join it with the House bill in
conference but I think McCain was
concerned because the house could just
pass the skinny bill as well and then
that goes to the president's desk and he
didn't want that to happen so in that
regard I think he did stand on principle
here
well that principle to whatever extent
it was heroic as it's being portrayed by
some did lead to the situation we have
now and the next question is what next
right
Obama care seems sort of like it's not
just this thing but it's part of our
health care system now it's not some
crazy appendage it's been around for
seven years it's by and large a you know
furthering the same for-profit insurance
system that we have but it did some good
things Trump and the Republican
establishment are really the losers here
and now they will do everything they can
to make Obamacare fail we might have
news about that in the next day or two
Obamacare is not in a death spiral it's
having the exact same issues that all of
health insurance is which is rising
premiums people who still can't afford
care there's nothing particularly
disastrous about Obama care it sucks
like our entire health care system sucks
just in slightly mitigated ways by
increasing the risk pool and increasing
some subsidies so what's next for Trump
Obamacare repeal is dead the travel ban
is in limbo at best tax reform is on the
back burner for now although some
Republicans are saying that's what they
want to get back into next the wall with
Mexico is laughable and Trump's new
NAFTA deal is really similar to the TPP
proposal that Donald Trump was against I
genuinely don't know what's next here
which is why and we're going to talk
about North Korea more in the next
segment which is why I am worried that
six months into his presidency Trump is
a pseudo lame duck and what now could
happen is an erratic or desperate move
to get himself involved in a military
escalation the top candidate right now
would be North Korea Syria is a
possibility Iran is a possibility and
that's why I'm really scared about the
next six months for Trump that is
interesting especially because it feels
as if Democrats are trying to run out
the clock and succeeding and doing so
already a quarter of the way to the
midterms and you think about what issues
he might be able to win on not many
because a lot of these bills you can't
just hide in Budget Reconciliation you
need 60 votes for say tax reform correct
I think the move here is maybe to go for
infrastructure because you can get
Democrats on board with that as well
maybe and Trump does want to do it in a
totally sort of capital crony capitalist
equate with handouts to all those
construction and real estate buddies but
if Democrats can get some compromise on
some issues that they want pet projects
whatever then that could be a
possibility Trump is going to need to
rebuild his influence and credibility
now particularly if Jeff session goes
and one of trumps last links to the
mainline Republican Party is sessions
right now so what happens if in one
session goes and this is why I'm worried
that this could push Trump into
haphazard and very erratic action with
maybe the top candidate North Korea if
not Syria or Iran and we'll talk about
that a little bit later in the program
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman follow me
there send me your thoughts there we'll
be back after the break
today's program is made possible in part
by blue apron the number-one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country for under 10 bucks a meal
they deliver seasonal recipes with
pre-portioned ingredients right to your
door I've been cooking with blue apron
now for over a year and I love it and I
love not wasting food I don't have to
figure out what to do with that extra
package of cilantro they send me the
exact amount of cilantro that the recipe
calls for no waste
at all it's also completely flexible so
you can customize your recipes it's each
week depending on your diet you can
choose delivery options that fit your
needs and they have the blue apron
freshness guarantee which promises every
ingredient arrives ready to cook or they
will make it right for you some of the
meals available in the coming month
include basil pesto chicken with summer
vegetable panzanella sauteed shrimp and
green beans with globe tomatoes spinach
and orzo pasta whole grain pasta and
summer vegetables with heirloom tomato
caprese salad and miso butter salmon and
lo mein noodles with cucumber and charm
tomatoes you can check out this week's
menu get your first three meals free
with free shipping by going to blue
apron comm slash Pakman support our
sponsors and support the David Pakman
show
three meals free with free shipping at
blue apron dot-com /pa k ma n